that's why I just think the way people
are nowadays men are the villains in
every scenario and anything that happens
to a woman if you flip it on its head
and it happened into a man it's always
worse because women are Saints we cannot
do anymore do you think so perfect no I
do not like she said that
tongue-in-cheek because you see her
smile I do not think so but I feel like
Society
I just think conversation to make it
seem like that is the consensus but even
like when we talk about cheating like if
the guy does it it's always we demonize
him but if the girl does it the first
question is always why like why what
made her cheat why did she cheat I no I
would I would say I would always ask why
did the guy cheat I always I don't think
that's do you think you think that's
common when you see it on when you see
it on say tick tock when they tell
cheating stories it's always that if you
look at any cheating story on Tick Tock
if it's a girl telling it the story of
how she cheated like they'll always say
oh well why did she cheats
what yeah but for the men it's like you
know if I say he cheated because he
hasn't slept his wife hasn't slept with
him in three years they still may come
out to be the bad guy yeah okay yeah
fair enough actually I don't think
you're wrong it's like you know one out
of four marriages is a sexless usually
on the man's part or like on the woman's
part yeah oh wow yeah 104. I've known
I've known somebody and been married
it's really cool yes
yeah yeah I don't think I could it's
easy to slip into could you remember
when you have babies right now then you
look at it no I'm sorry it's easy to
slip into I honestly I just feel like
when we have conversations about sex in
marriage like women have to be honest
there are points in your marriage where
you have to make an effort where you
have to look at your husband and say
okay he needs to take one for the team
in this capacity and I may not feel like
it for the foreseeable so let me Avail
myself in the same way you would want
like your husband or your partner to
eval himself in whatever of our scenario
or even the same I just feel like it is
not that uncommon for a woman to not
want to have sex because when you become
when you are a woman of a house you've
got a lot going on especially if you
work as well there's a lot happening and
you have babies and stuff like that I
just feel like sometimes yes
like the wife is required to make an
effort she's not always going to feel
like it but some women choose not to
make an effort some women are like I
will wait until I feel like it and you
will wait until I feel like it can I ask
you a question so if you didn't feel
like it you'd still do it
well if he wanted to I just feel like my
husband but
yes yeah like I will I will
he needs me in that like I just feel
like for men it's not always
I'm horny like it's
like their way of connecting to you
they're like they want to be close to
you and they don't want to sit down and
have a gossip about what they did they
don't want to listen to your like
stories that you say is going to be two
minutes but actually it's an hour and a
half they want to connect like that way
like just sometimes you have to Avail
yourself yeah
sure you watch me another one of those
podcasts before Pearl no you remember
the one we asked about the women what's
your opinion Auntie what if what if she
doesn't feel like it I was like she
don't feel like it you know just like
read a book bend over and just like you
know watch TV be on the phone
not not always because the fact of the
matter is is if you are with someone
that person loves you and understands
you so if you don't feel like it there's
going to be times that's fine yeah yeah
leave me alone but then sometimes like
you may not feel like it for like two
months wow too that long don't look at
me
I'm not about you I'm not telling my
story
okay okay okay
it could be that okay you might have had
a baby you might have been traumatic
whatever
who knows so if you having a baby not
talking about you but just like you know
yeah if he was having a baby you didn't
feel like is there other ways that you
can please your man uh okay then just
checking okay we all yeah we all know
there's a real grown unaware
no I said this before and I and I said
that you know basically a woman should
refuse a man you know if it's her
husbands yeah I mean yeah exactly but
for a woman they want to make love for a
man it's just like give me five minutes
I think that's okay what happens if
you're really angry at him about
something he's done and he wants it
right there and then like do you do it I
can resolve the angle what happens
[Laughter]
that could be better than counseling
yeah
you're being so angry that I thought
when I was six I've never had makeup and
that's the best kind sorry Mom I'm just
saying I've never had makeup so
and I feel like people come closer and
it's nice yeah but that's where that's
why you get stuck in your toxic
situation I'm not having a go because
I've done the same
yeah if you're happy I wouldn't do it to
mask I think mask is the perfect word
yeah you can't have sex if you're not
happy you can't make love yeah yeah you
have to so you've got to make sure that
the problems solve you can't just say oh
yeah you know everything's fine but deep
inside you're angry yeah you have to
clear it because yeah you know you can't
have Angry sex but I don't think you can
have sex if you're not fully in it
anyway well that's me personally I don't
know about you I'll do it just to let
him shut up I'll give him five minutes I
also don't think foreplay works
they get you in the mood anyone can get
you in the mood yeah right man no you're
right yeah it depending how you feel
yeah but yeah like yeah the general of
all is if you want to eat you like you
have to prepare it like yeah cook it
marinated
how long how long do you think a guy if
he goes without like okay I'm trying to
phrase this question so how long let's
say you haven't had sex with him in a
month is it acceptable for him to cheat
no like like at what point
um have you like not slept with your guy
where it's kind of understandable that
he steps out because we could agree
probably that if you haven't slept with
him in two years he's probably gonna
step out and some men don't sleep with
him in a month I think he's over I think
it's happening he's finished with me
yeah I've got a question actually off
the back of that no it's not you it's
like you not sleeping yeah and all
seriously never like
a guy has been deprived for that long
like get to the point of saying you've
deprived me for this long I feel like I
need it and I'm gonna get it like just
talk to me yeah communication
to me and come come to me and be like
look this is how I'm feeling retiter and
I haven't tried I think the same as an
argument and I haven't tried to resolve
it yeah resolve it at that point leave
me but that's I feel like that's simple
for a lot of guys
they lose custody to their kids no I
think I know I agree it's not that
simple but if you want me to answer the
question
no but in real life everything's a
little bit more complex than that so I
get it there's exceptions of everything
I think that well yeah and I honestly I
just feel like even like me as a male
person like I've told my husband this
before I don't feel like cheating is a
deal breaker if
I just don't feel like changing I feel
like you can literally work through
anything I really do but on like just to
answer your question right no no no yeah
but at least like two months okay two
months is two months for that okay no at
least like some people will be like Oh
I'm having sex in two weeks
what aspect are we okay so why wouldn't
you be having sex with him sometimes
whatever the reason yeah some girl yeah
you can yeah like some girls do it to
like control the guy
yeah sadistics I think sometimes I
remember one in four marriages are
sexless I mean maybe she married she
didn't marry the guy she wanted and
she's not really attracted to him
anymore yeah I mean there's a million
reasons I think if it started that way
then it's different if it's changed like
throughout you need to look at what's
changed it but sometimes it's also like
where you are at mentally yeah yeah and
if you're someone who like suffers from
depression that can affect how you feel
sexually yeah and unfortunately sorted
and unfortunate unfortunately
unfortunately like it's not personal to
your partner but obviously it does
affect your partner but you should be
able to communicate clearly why you're
feeling like you're feeling so that he
doesn't feel iced out because men will
literally if you if you look if you go
to touch you and you're like he's gonna
feel iced out so and then hopefully you
have a compassionate partner I just
don't know what you could tell I'm like
baby we're not gonna have sex for three
months but this is how I'm feeling yeah
yes can you understand what mine did I
think foundationally what helps is if
both both people in the relationship can
agree that if we haven't had sex in a
while there's actually a problem because
one might not see it like the woman that
is withholding six Humanity has a
problem but if we can agree that I I
don't feel I have not felt like having
sex with you for like over a week or two
weeks she within herself should be able
to say I may not know why but this is
definitely a problem subconsciousness
yeah but but you you always know why you
just need to dig deep like I knew why I
I at first I was like oh I'm not too
sure and then I did and I've told him I
was like this is why and he was
we have an open not open relationship in
terms of other people but in terms of
like openly communicating I don't feel
like no one should be having sex if you
can't talk about sex you certainly
shouldn't be having been in a
relationship you can't talk about sex
with your partner and why you don't have
sex or what you like what you don't like
etc etc and hopefully the person that
you have respect you as a human being
and says okay I can see why you're going
through that perhap like do you know how
long I know if you can honestly say look
I don't know how I'm gonna feel if that
person then turns around and says well I
thought like at least wait a certain
time period before you go okay it's been
a while is anything changing no yeah
what a woman should get proactive about
it
what is the longest has any of us been
without sex in a relationship and who
stopped it what's the longest you've
been in your relationship without sex so
I can't answer that
okay can I yeah
I just jumped in so different I don't
know if anyone else okay
I don't
so one of my exes was anorexic
he had an eating disorder
and I used to hate sleeping with him
because I could feel his hip bones and
it used to make me feel
uncomfortable it would hurt
and it put me off and
trying to help someone overcome that and
support them but also trying to be
intimate with them when you're not
feeling it because it physically hurts
is a hard thing to stay in
so um that was not a very
sexy relationship so how long was it
that was a year and a bit no I mean how
long without that sex no no no no no oh
because he started he started gaining I
couldn't do it to myself
wait did you cheat on him no I've never
I've never I couldn't
if I'm either in or I'm out I don't run
around in Gray areas I don't it's just
not how I roll so for me
that we weren't intimate for about a
good
it was like on and off because some I'm
trying to think probably about a good
four or five months but just okay you
didn't have sex with him for four or
five months yeah and it's because you
didn't want to did he know the reason
why I had no I had to be honest in the
end do you think if the roles were
reversed yeah you would have like taken
that okay and you know what it's
interesting you're saying that I called
myself out on it today because my friend
said to me that a guy she was with
made a comment about her weight in the
bedroom and it made me reflect and think
God I've done that to a guy
and I thought who the hell am I
to say that I felt bad
but then he asked me why and I I don't
lie you know I'm gonna be honest with
you if we're in a relationship
[Music]
and um
how did he respond yeah it was hard for
him but then he actually got well like
he started training in the gym he
started eating properly we cooked
together like that's why I think that I
came into his life to help him with that
it's really interesting like the it's
like it seems like men can accept
criticism a lot better than women
because you know it was hard for him
that in the bedroom like how dare you
did it guys would you not get offended
if your man was picking something
especially in the bedroom yeah which is
why I felt really bad when she told me
that story because it made me think you
know what I did that to someone and I
didn't mean it in a malicious way no
well you should have to go away the
question he asked me the truth he said
tell me I don't really felt like I feel
like yeah I just think four or five
bucks
I didn't just come out with it in a very
long way I was diplomatic yeah but I
don't know
if I'm gonna be really honest is
spiritually attacked me as well it
didn't it didn't just get me physically
it made me feel when I'm the kind of
person when I'm involved with someone I
take on everything like their emotions
their Aura like I feel
so I just want to ask so would you not
attracted to him anymore because of that
but when you got together you said this
is what he was like so surely you would
know I was attracted to him it was
painful to have sex with him oh because
of his hip bones sorry I thought you
said you wasn't finding it attractive
sorry okay it's also the it wasn't sexy
yeah yeah that so what's the longest I'm
waiting to hear from a video she's five
months no no I mean each person what's
the longest each person two days yeah
and he's watching like not even 48 Hours
yeah like two days no that's what I
meant because that's what I meant
because if you're in a relationship
I can't see myself going fine you know
what yeah I think if you've got no if
you used to her clothes me personally
after a couple of days I'm like what's
wrong yeah yeah after a couple of days
intimacy is a big part of a relationship
I think it's easy I think it's easier to
go longer if when you're not living
together like like me and my partner
wasn't living together so yeah that's
why it probably had that
time but if we were living together I
100 believe it would have been as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible